[Music]  ladies and Gentlemen please welcome  Whitney Houston  [Applause]  a common criticism of you your music  isn't black enough well who said that  that's just Bull and it makes me angry  actually it's hateful and uninformed a  whole life she ain't black no she ain't  white enough well how about she's not  obedient enough  how about she ain't fearful enough  music is not a color to me it has no  boundaries I've seen what I want to sing  be how I want to be and reach as big an  audience as I can  no one is like you you can sing  Whitney your daddy's princess  we're building something here so you  just keep singing Daddy  my money  I trusted you you want me to look out  for me  [Music]  YouTube has spent a lot of time together  it's damaging the brand since when's a  little girl become the brand I miss that  don't even worry about it you're Whitney  Houston  [Music]  [Applause]  love  [Applause]  someone I ever know  [Applause]  [Music]